inside of the fourth poorest building
and settled the verse two floor Masters
are introduced to everyone before their
fight it's shown that the Grim Creeper
himself the one and only hasoka Morrow
is pitted up against crolo Lucifer in
their first match as a floor Master as
we all know from the anime and his goal
of taking down the spiders ahsoka's
lifetime dream of wanting this battle
has finally been realized he makes it
extremely clear to the spider boy that
he doesn't want the match to become a
simple sparring session to which crolo
agrees stating that this will indeed be
a battle to the death but just before we
do go any further if you guys want me to
keep covering these battles that happen
throughout the Hana Hana manga by the
south of kurapaker or the princes then
push this video to 10K likes and I'll
make sure to cover each individual
battle that happens inside of the
succession Arc as it continues releasing
of course also make sure to subscribe
with that notification Bell on so you
don't miss out on the latest drops but
enough of me barking on is per usual
let's get into the battle inside of
Heaven's Arena
standing there separating the fighters
the judge explains that weapons are
indeed allowed in this fight then
quickly initiates the battle instantly
as the battle begins crawler pulls out
his book while hishsoka and tandem
readies a card any flash Crawley reveals
a controlled antenna before inserting it
into the back of the judge's neck so
this is actually another spider's
technique the number six charl Knox
ninability called black voice having
seen this ability before hasoka realized
that crowler was actually evading him
after the exorcism because remember you
know like what happened with the train
and all earlier on in the series in
order to prepare for their fight now
like he went around amassing abilities
he thought he'd need to take down hisoka
comfortably cheekily crolo then reveals
yet another antenna showing his opponent
that he has the ability to control him
if subdued before he demandsly judge to
attack Ahsoka quite comfortably though
our beautiful pink head goon head kicks
the judge while getting ready for crolo
to close then for a strike however the
spider takes him off guard by pulling a
faint and suddenly appearing above
hisoka crolo unleashes a brutal flurry
of storm as Ahsoka barely manages to
block the incoming barrage he Ponders on
how exactly the antenna ability works
and if it can control more than a single
person at once with crrollo still
continuing his assault it's revealed
that hersoka attached the bungee gun
from his own foot to the judge's chest
and because of it he activated the
ability elastic love pulling the target
at Max Speed towards them allowing
hisoka to then Escape Carlo's line of
sides Crowley quickly Dodges and directs
the judge towards his opponent again who
realizes that this spider is using the
strategy with the antennae to constantly
put him on edge as he has an insta kill
method absolutely loving this feeling
swelling up inside of him though Ahsoka
rejoices and slashes the judges neck
with one of his cards yet and taking him
by surprise there's a small Blast from
the judge's chest causing Ahsoka to
reactively use Bungie to repel to the
ceiling standing behind the falling
judge crawler's hands reveal two symbols
placed upon them on the right hand he
has a moon shape or their minor sign in
the middle and on his left a sun shape
with a plus sign in the middle this
technique is called the Sun and Moon
destruction confused Ahsoka wonders how
it's possible for him to use an ability
with two hands while not even holding
the book that possesses a set ability as
explained that crawler's son and
moonability impresses the mark of the
moon on his right and the sun on his
left and the two symbols touched they
cause an explosion he can impress these
marks instantly which will cause a small
blast but to produce a devastating blast
he has to touch the target for three to
five seconds continuing and giving us a
reason for how we managed to use the
nobility even though the book was closed
crowler reveals the ability double fakes
bookmark theme which allows him to
maintain an ability by bookmarking its
Pages even if the book is closed
accordingly he can also have a bookmark
on one ability and have it open to
another allowing him to use both
abilities at the same time Ahsoka who
guessed that he could probably use three
not just two abilities because the
bookmark counts as one itself inquires
more but it's actually shown that the
bookmark isn't a stolen ability as
crolu's own ability that he came up with
in combination with the board basically
it's an ability inside of a theft type
of ability to use two stolen techniques
at once crawler though just Trader wants
to use hands and mainly does this
because the real Advantage is not having
to hold the book then as things start to
heat back up Chromo declares that if
Ahsoka keeps us up he'll set a new
record for the number of abilities
crawlers used on someone taking it one
step further though like the man like
the man ain't done yet crawler reveals
yet another ability order stand proof of
humanity this is like pretty similar to
the previous ability but unlike
shalnark's ability order stamp
manipulates puppets black voice is the
superior as it gives total control but
due to its higher level of control it's
limited to two people at a time Auto
stamp though is a much simpler ability
when it comes to control and because of
that he can manipulate many with a
bookmark reappearing crawler marks
another page in his book while
explaining to hisoka it has really seen
this ability before using gallery fake
Divine left hand demonic right hand he
makes a copy of the Dead judge before as
you could probably assume he uses the
stamp ability on the forehead of the
copy he explains that unlike himself the
former owner of order stamp didn't
consider a corpse and a puppet similar
inanimate objects so while the corpse
can't be controlled with the ability a
copy of it can telling the copy to stand
crawler explains that for the original
owner once the puppet had been beheaded
it was no longer a puppet which honestly
is super interesting like I really love
how just in-depth each technique inside
of hanahana gets you can compare it to
like a binding vowel in some ways with
jjk like to some aspects of it yeah I
find with jjk the least specific you are
about a Bonnie vowel or with one the
more broken it can actually be whereas
here with Hana I feel that the
conditions can either hinder or help
someone depending on the scenario and
situation they actually find themselves
in with that all out of the way though
crolukamansi puppet to break Ahsoka
claiming that a puppet usually created
by copying a human reacts to kill orders
depending on the original personality of
the human though as we've just seen if
the command is made more simple they
will always focus on doing that exact
task until completion not bothered by
one puppet so easily twists he copies
hit off and crawler confirms that this
stops the puppet causing order stamp to
disappear yet if you've noticed like
Ahsoka just did the puppet itself Still
Remains which is for the simple fact
that he hasn't deactivated Gallery fake
so when he finally does vanish soku will
be able to confirm that crowler's
abilities have deactivated knowing that
at least one more ability Still Remains
one more as well which is actually like
crazy damasoka's only got the legendary
bungee gum I don't know how in the world
he's going to win here maybe he could do
some like some of that creepy stuff like
twerk on crowler for a bit to freak him
out but I fully doubt he's even gonna do
that all right crolo's probably too old
for him to act that way anyway revealing
the sneak stability either way crawler
shows opposing arrows on each hand this
is called convert hands transfer student
if crolo touches a target with his right
hand it will take his form and vice
versa with his left and touching the
tackle with both hands will cause the
toe to switch forms thinking on the spot
Ahsoka wonders if crawler would be able
to make a copy using gallery fakes hand
marks but realizes that having holy book
would get in his way with all of this
being done to justify Ahsoka Prolo
explains one more thing and the most
important bit of information if an
ability's original owner dies it
disappears from his book and can never
be used again yet one of the abilities
just explained remains in this book even
after the owner's death initially
confused Ahsoka quickly comes to the
realization that involved nin becoming
stronger after death watch if you
remember back to the fight with gun and
Pito her inability like this one stated
in the book actually stayed around after
her death and if I'm not wrong was also
stronger at that exact point but because
of how broken gone Wars it wasn't really
like visible to us at the time the
ability inclusion here is that of the
Sun and Moon technique the original
owner was an elder of meteos City who
had used his ability to turn one of the
residents into a bomb to deliver a
message in addition and just like crolo
the Elder didn't see a difference
between humans and puppets so pretty
much and just like Ahsoka confirms once
marked with the sun and moon it cannot
be removed until it explodes even his
book is closed or put away with Trello
entirely confident in his coming Victory
he asks Ahsoka if he still wants to
continue with the big beautiful boy
heplexane yes beginning to move now
Chloe thinks that humans are indeed
interesting quickly he activates his
bookmarkability and leaps backwards
towards the crowd having gained some
distance he pulls out black voice
pulling out two of his antennae at the
same time not bothered at all though
like Ahsoka just wants to throw some
hands right now man heavily chases him
through the arena before starting up
through the audience members to keep
following he knows that if he gets too
close the antennae could prove fatal but
if he doesn't attack then he'll fall
straight for crawlow's trap as he
approaches the spider a giant man
controlled by crolo jumps in the way
completely blocking hisoka's Vision
thinking that crawler would die to the
left hisoka comfortably takes down the
larger dude but annoyingly another
controlled man leaps out towards him
figurine that he's now used both antenna
to control the attacking men Ahsoka
dispatches the attacking one but due to
the momentary lack of sight on crolo he
lost his exact location beginning to get
troubled Ahsoka tries to do see in the
order of his moves surely he used black
voice then bookmarked it activated
convert hands transformed into someone
else with his left hand moved the
bookmark to convert hands then close the
Box line weights with floods of
terrified Spectators sprinting for the
exit Ahsoka notices both antenna are
gone and guesses that crolo reeled the
moon was something like a fishing line
noticing some of the audience members
have been duplicated Ahsoka realizes
their Gallery fake must be activated
with confirmed hands deactivated and
that crolo has taken another person's
clothes to disguise himself at that
moment a horde of audience members
suddenly began jumping and dashing
towards Ahsoka or with visible stamps on
their foreheads with them getting closer
Ahsoka tries figuring out crawler's set
of moves his short crawler would have
had to open the book to Gallery fake
bookmark it create a crowd of copies
activate order stamp then finally
command all of them to break Ahsoka he
guesses that there must be 50 or so
puppets and more who haven't been given
commands yet with the incoming barrage
Ahsoka thinks quickly and activates
bungee gum to filling himself up towards
the ceiling and some Daisy level of
horde mentality all of the puppets climb
on top of one another raging and
grabbing and Diving at Ahsoka doing
their best to try and break him being
caught up with the waterfall of dolls
Ahsoka is taken off guard as crawler
suddenly appears behind him has held for
Change and acts as if he's going to
throw a punch that quickly changes at
the last second to kick hisoka in the
back of the head instead of falling to
the ground below floating there in the
air though hisoka exclaims that he
absolutely loves this feeling having
landed on the ground he rises while
fiending off a plethora of Puppets using
this to his Advantage trollo darts in
and out of the Mist constantly jabbing
and kicking Ahsoka over and over again
knowing that he needs to slim down the
number of dolls Ahsoka continues and
manages to dispatch two of the puppets
while considering what krollu's Next
plan of action will be suddenly crawler
appears from above riddle to strike down
exactly like last time Ahsoka guesses
that crolo probably knows what he's
about to do but goes through with it
either way and activates his bungee gum
from his left hand connecting it to the
Civic head he then flings the head
towards crowlo in an attempt to stop the
attack however he easily manages to
dodge it in mid-air before once again
stomping down on her Soaker sitting her
face first into the floor have you ever
prepared himself though Soca quickly
retaliates by using bungee gum from his
left leg on the other head striking
trollo in the face with hurts so for all
of the Curious people out there the
average adult male head weighs around
seven to eight kgs or as much as a
professional bowler's bowling ball after
striking crawler with his civet head
from his left leg Ahsoka uses the other
dose head attached to his left hand and
forcefully strikes the spider's other
side Rising back to his feet once again
he notices another barrage of Puppets
charging towards him using the doll's
head as a weapon the absolutely yolked
up Ahsoka whoops it around and simply
beheading any of the approaching clones
spotting crawler in the crowd Ahsoka
tries attacking him throwing the head
forth but he easily sidesteps the attack
while disappearing back into the group
Ahsoka realizes that if he dispatches
all of the puppets crawler would have to
maintain the ability anymore and can go
back to making more copies for the
bookmarked Gallery fake as a result he
whittles down all of the fodder clones
leaving one standing but assam's it
literally while taking it hostage
element crawler's actions in his eyes
crawler can either keep order stem
activated and give a new command to the
puppet's line and weight or deactivate
the ability begin making more puppets
with Gallery fake and then use order
stamp again or convert hands to change
his appearance not gonna liar Takashi is
a freaking genius writing the script
with covert as well has been a complete
mind trip for me like it's honestly so
confusing at points trying to ride out
these abilities everything is just so
in-depth so I hope I was able to convey
the use of the techniques correctly and
all that kind of jazz by the way me
continuing me and my dyslexic ass loves
to mess things up however the stem on
the puppet's forehead disappears so
hisoka assumes that crolo has gone with
a second option which in his eyes is an
even bigger force of people allowing him
to safely pick up a new disguise Ahsoka
continues to consider Carlo's next
action and guesses that if he's making
copies while on the Move he'll go where
he already has copies ready as he
suspected he spots Carlo and the
audience and dashes towards him sitting
a clone head in his Direction easily
dodging the head once more Ahsoka
notices crowler has both hands covered
and considers the possibility that crolo
isn't using order stamp or convert hands
but has the black voice phone in his
pocket as Ahsoka continues his assault
swinging and doing his best to protect
crawler's movements he releases his gum
from the floor which he had also
attached to the back of several audience
members as per guns shrink the people
randomly go flying towards the spider
taking him completely by surprise with
Corolla being mugged by a bunch of
random sticky clones Ahsoka takes the
opportunity and hurls his head towards
him forcing Carla to jump into his
preset trap catching his left foot with
bungee gum with crolo completely unable
to dodge he throws his head straight
into crolo's back before then with the
other hand slamming him down onto the
ground below completely and utterly
destroying him with the impact as kolo's
body lies there bloody and broken as you
suspected it's revealed that it was
actually an audience member made to look
like crolo Ahsoka is confused about how
he even made a copy leave himself will
come through hands and manipulated the
dude with black voice while the bookmark
was still on convert hands they quickly
realizes that the casley problem must be
the Sun and Moon ability up until now he
had been worried about the mark being
permanent until it explodes but that
isn't it the real issue is that a puppet
marked with the ability won't vanish
remembering crawler's previous statement
about the Sun and Moon ability taking up
two hands he realizes that when another
ability is bookmarked with the book held
in his right hand he can still use the
sun and moon to make the mark of the sun
with his left hand crawler would also
said that once a copy vanishes Ahsoka
could conclude that Gallery fake had
been deactivated but he never said that
hisoku could conclude that Gallery fake
is still in use while the copy remains
so most likely his chain of command
won't be what it was before which was
activate Gallery fake book Market close
the book create a crowd of copies
activate order stamp then command them
all to break Ahsoka but is more likely
to actually be activate Gallery fake
bookmarker then close the book create a
crowd of copies activate the Sun and
Moon and Priestly Sunmark Army copies
deactivate either or both of them and
because remember how the Sun and Moon
has a post-death nin at one vanish
therefore it allows him to freely
activate order stamp then he finally
commands them all to break Ahsoka which
is just the biggest mine trip of having
to like actually figure that out Med
Battle just goes to show how strong
Ahsoka actually is the fact that this
man has one ability with like his bungee
gum and he's able to take on crolo who
just has a plethora of amazing
techniques he can use anyway because of
the additional steps involved in
krollo's plan Ahsoka realizes that there
are fewer puppets than he had initially
thought more likely around 20 or 30.
looking around he notices that most of
the audience has remained since they
think they'll be out of the range of the
fight he realizes that Crowley wanted
too much more time because the
paramedics and Security will arrive in
10 minutes and the remaining puppets
will be mistaken for the injured
resulting and then being taken away
before he can use them randomly a bunch
of audience members begin to flee
running for their lives as others chase
them down Ahsoka guesses that crolo has
given student puppet's instructions in
order to confuse the crowd and create
further chaos from it surrounded by The
Spectators the announcer lets everyone
know that the paramedics and security
are on their way so just stay calm
interfering in the broadcast though an
unknown person grabs the headset and
commands all of the dolls to break
hisoka all of a sudden hundreds of
clones begin charging down towards
Ahsoka clambering over all of the
barriers and sprinting across the open
arena still holding the head and his
hand Ahsoka who's absolutely feigning
that good good right now readies himself
for the incoming Showdown sending out
five or so strains of Bungee gum from
his fingers on his right hand and
attaching them to the chest of five
puppets he Twirls the massive puppets
together in the air and uses them as a
human Hammer to push back any puppets
that get too close with the dolls being
too fragile ahsoka's weapon eventually
breaks the birds but almost instantly
after he attempts to form another while
fainting off even more puppets
single-handed leave with one more
jumping at him from behind it's shown
that crello had stood in weight amid the
audience using black voice to of a
specific doll commands with Ahsoka
having retrieved the head once more
crolo activates his sun and moon ability
commanding it to explode pull completely
off guard the head detonates and
ahsoka's hand and wiped out four of his
fingers and shock from his missing
thingies and even larger explosion goes
off behind him and because of this
Ahsoka quickly realizes what crolo just
did back earlier in the fight when
Ahsoka had dispatched those two clones
of their heads crawler pretended to be
reeling from the hurt but was actually
keeping track of the body and they
turned it into a maximum power bomb
afterwards he had imprinted A random
audience member with a mark of the Moon
and manipulated them with black voice to
touch the mark of the sun on the body
resulting in an explosion of both the
body and its head which hasoka held
sadly for a thingalus Ahsoka his gum
that had previously attached from his
left hand to the ceiling had gone but he
throws that all aside and uses what's
the liver's bungee gum to bring a puppet
towards him before popping off its head
becoming surrounded once again he uses
the body to bash away any approach
puppets then as The Horde starts closing
in shoots a strand of gum from his left
leg to the upper tier of the stadium
pulling him to some safety the horde of
Puppets again amass themselves like
before on their Daisy Speck to pursue
Ahsoka but he pushes them back using a
variety of Bungee abilities and
continues to flee not wanting him to
flee Crowley gives a command to a bunch
of the puppets telling them to get to
the second floor find Ahsoka and her
self-destruct when they get right next
to him suddenly multiple puppets leap
off the balcony right next to Mr Morrow
and bring their hands together causing a
devastating explosion that sends a burnt
Ahsoka flying across the stadium with
him now falling down towards the
spectators below at Sean that Ahsoka
even lost a part of his leg from the
blow and due to that he goes to use
bungee gum with his other leg to escape
however crolo from the other side of the
stadium had begun hurdling audience
members towards him causing Ahsoka to
lose his grip with Bungie and begin
Falling Again having fallen onto the
ground below Now The Horde quickly
begins surrounding and Diving onto
hisoka leaving out pink creep with no
other option than to bring his arms
closed as an enormous explosion of
Puppets erupt around him
nearby and just you know just a few
blocks away from Heaven's Arena our
reporter states that a massive explosion
has just occurred as smokers seem
bellowing from the top of the tower
hundreds of people flee from the bottom
running in the street below while at the
same time firemen and paramedics slowly
make their way to the war like saying
apparently this entire battle has
happened with a member's only audience
and that one fighter is believed to be
responsible for bringing a bomb into the
arena finally the reporter mentions that
there have been several casualties
including hisoka Morrow but the exact
cause of the incident is still unclear
standing over the Char girl Chad Ahsoka
chauhnak which is the guy who like
originally owns the black voice ability
explains to cool topi in marchy that
around 200 puppets swarmed hisoka trying
to break him before the bomb puppets
could get close enough and explode
because of that he presumes that the
puppets ended up acting as a cushion to
dampen some of the explosive damage and
because of that ultimately hisoka
suffocated from a lack of oxygen while
the others having confirmed his demise
they all go to leave but Machi says that
he paid her in advance which is just
like all of his other previous fights in
Heaven's Arena so she'll tend to his
wounds before leaving even if he is
actually dead well the other's gone now
marchy closes hisoka's eyes and studies
the severe damage around his neck noting
that she will clean up his face as well
but as she leans in closer Aura suddenly
swells around his corpse and much easily
stunned quickly remembering that
post-mortem nin can become stronger as
ahsoka's heart begins to beat once more
it's shown that this crazy man is
pumping his own heart with his own hand
around known him to once again sat down
on some more of that beautiful oxygen so
you know how like ah soak at the end of
that fight had gone into the Fatal
position while it's actually shown that
he was giving something a go he knew
that if he was going to die he had to
try something massive and literally on
the spot Christ at a new ability asking
it to Spring him to life stroke him all
over and revive him as he dies now back
after the battle soca's eyes fly open as
he coughs and splutters quickly Rising
back to his feet with a surprise look on
his face he sees marchy kneeling beside
him and greets her asking if he really
had just died to which he confirms she
offers to stitch him up but Ahsoka
quickly declines wanting to use bungee
Camp to stop the bleeding around his
neck and face he then uses texture
surprise to recreate the flesh that was
blown off in the explosion covering up
the damage to his face and making a
rubber prosthetic for his left hand and
right leg with marching not thinking
that she's needed anymore she goes to
leave but Ahsoka suddenly appears behind
her wraps his arms around before then
mobile lighting Hill with bungee come he
asks Machi to tell the rest of the Trope
that he will fight any of them until
he's killed all of them utterly enraging
marchy not listening to her though he
calmly walks away as she angrily yells
for him to let her go elsewhere nearby
crolo having left the arena is seen
walking through a busy street while
talking on the phone with someone about
the karken royal family he assumes he'll
have a plethora of jewels and bridges on
board saying that they're gonna plan to
steal Oliver crolo who's actually like
talking to charl knock right now asks
him if he wants a cell phone ability bad
but says that the antennas are gone
however shall not says it is fine for
now hanging up shall not wonders why
cortopia is taking so long in the
bathroom maybe it's because he's having
a fair dump but anyway as his phone
begins ringing again he pays utterly no
attention to it as he suddenly sees
Ahsoka live in the bathroom carrying
something in his hand immediately he
darts towards the narrow Vibe Ahsoka who
notices him tossing kurotobi's head
towards this absolute Muppet shall not
quickly catches it and as he looks at
the face of his friend Ahsoka dashes
forward and knocks him to the ground
with an extremely powerful strike
moments later a beaten spider is seen
strung up and tied to a swing while the
other spider just dropped down below him
gleefully Ahsoka proudly says two down
ten to go
and you know that finally brings us to
the very end of what is the hisoka
versus crolo Beatdown inside of Heaven's
Arena and you know his first little
whack off the top of these Fighters I'm
super happy to see Ahsoka finally doing
his thing and getting away from the kids
and actually fighting adults for a
change it's absolutely amazing I love it
I love it if you guys want to see more
stuff like this then do what I said
subscribe and push this video to 10K
likes holy I'm losing my voice
right now and let me know what fight you
want me to cover from Hunter Hunter next
down in the comment section below